i'm a big fan of the show great to talk
with you uh i guess i'm gonna start with
the most important question right up
front um when i don't know if you've
been able to go to cons again or you
know i don't know when it's all gonna
start back up but have you tried talking
to the person that owns grudge about
making appearances with grudge at the
cons because i really do think that um
you know you with grudge in the pictures
you'd be like selling out in two seconds
um
i'm sure one way or another we'll have
to make that happen because enough
people have asked for it and you have to
give the people what they want so we'll
have to make that work but um
i don't know it'll be very expensive to
get grudge
at a convention she she's not cheap
we can be
we can fit in the budget but right
right grudge is number one
then sneaker and about 40 down is me and
david
um
i don't think grudge could handle doing
photos
maybe one or two and that's it and
that's it and then so temperament
yeah right that that's so basically
someone has to spend a lot of money to
be the one or anyway i'm i'm off on the
tangent listen lots of money right
the headline of this interview is you
know it's just
anyway um so uh i am i love learning
about the behind the scenes or the
making of tv shows and movies what do
you guys think would surprise people to
learn about the making of discovery
um we're not actually shooting in space
what would surprise people
i think i think it would surprise people
how much of the ship is like contiguous
like you could you can walk a full loop
in a hallway
uh and then off of that is me and
burnham's room and then over here is the
transporter
where we used to have it you know so i
think people would be surprised like how
much you feel like you're on a starship
when you're shooting on set
that the locations are super practical
and they all are linked yeah it is very
impressive yeah
yeah i i i would love to see that up
close um
uh i love uh the fact that this season
seems like it's you guys dealing with
like a science problem and not a villain
and i love that now mind you i could be
wrong i'm just basing this off the
trailers but what can you tease about
this season and is it that where you're
dealing with you know what i mean like a
science issue
right i think it feels very much like
that like classic star trek thing where
it's like we have this huge problem and
we don't even know where to begin yeah
to analyze it to predict it to
help
people with this issue you know and um
and so that feels very star trek like a
truly impossible situation and having to
like patiently and ardently science it
out and work it out
um that does feel very
like old school
yeah
especially this season
because it it um
what we have to science out is something
that's happened
that's affected
someone in the camp isn't it so it has a
different
weight of of
responsibility and and shock
and grief
right and we're in such unfamiliar
in such an unfamiliar space and dealing
with something that we've never dealt
with before we're very very limited
information to try and understand this
thing and it also feels very um pressing
with time yeah
it's painstakingly long
that the time it takes to find bits of
information to understand this thing but
yeah we're up against the clock at the
same time yeah
i i'm a big fan one of the things i like
about discovery is that you guys are in
the future and it's completely uh open
like anything can happen what do you
guys love about the show taking place so
far in the future
yeah i guess it feels more like um open
yeah like what you're saying that it
feels more open-ended we're less
beholden to fitting in within a
pre-existing timeline so then it has
this quality that like the other shows
had where they didn't know what was
coming next where you get just get to
like work on the like frontier of
imagination you don't have to serve so
many masters you just get to ask
yourself questions and get to be really
creative in terms of like finding new
ways to tell stories new questions to
ask um and those very special kinds of
questions that only star trek in its
like sort of forum can explore so i
think i think it's very good for the
show it's a very good place for us to be
working it is
it's it's it's great because you do have
that freedom but then at the same time
you have so much freedom
where where do you explore where do you
go what story do you want to tell yeah
on that note i got to stop i'm just
going to say congrats on the show cannot
wait to watch the new season thank you
for your time thank you so much pleasure
cool and again grudge conventions i'm
telling you
you said it stephen you said it